Salut les Mentalos, aujourd'hui on va parler des micros expressions du visage
J'en profite également pour souhaiter la bienvenue à tous les nouveaux qui viennent d'arriver sur la chaine
J'ai un message à la fin de la vidéo pour tous les abonnés
Donc ce sera à la fin de la vidéo après la outro
Dans notre visage, on a 94 muscles différents et dans notre cou 85 muscles différents
C'est beaucoup en général on utilise environ 10 000 expressions du visage différentes mais on les vois très très peu.
On utilise donc des expressions, on les contrôle ou pas
mais en général on les contrôle, on maitrise un petit peu ce qu'on fait
et les micro expressions elles durent très peu de temps
1/25 de seconde jusqu'à 1/2 seconde grand maximum.
Et c'est bien le but de ce master class
pour la 246e vidéo de l'année je me suis dis qu'on allait parler des micro-expressions incontrolées
celles qui passent très furtivement
celles qu'on ne maitrise pas consciemment
et qui donnent donc des indications non-verbales sur ce que l'on ressent
tout l'enjeu est là, c'est lié à des émotions, c'est lié à des sentiments, c'est lié à ce que l'on ressent intérieurement
c'est à dire que si on se force à faire travailler les muscles d'une micro expression particulière
alors ça va faire des changements internes dans le corps et dans l'état d'esprit
ça va changer notre émotion.
Essayer de faire ça en même temps que moi
Vous détendez le bas du visage, vous levez les sourcils
Vous écarquillez au maximum les yeux et vous essayez de rapprocher comme ça vos sourcils l'un de l'autre
comme ça le plus possible
De les rapprocher de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus, de plus en plus
et là ça provoque un léger sentiment de peur.
vous retrouvez cette sensation d'angoisse
Alors, elle est légère évidemment, vous allez pas avoir peur en regardant ma vidéo
mais ça vous permet de comprendre le rapport entre les micros expressions et les émotions
Une micro expression c'est vrai, c'est pas truqué. On peut truquer un sentiment de joie,
on peut truquer un sentiment de peur
on peut faire semblant sur son visage, c'est aussi ce que font les comédiens d'ailleurs.
mais l'expression réelle des sentiments fait travailler certains muscles
qu'on ne contrôle pas habituellement
Et ça, on peut pas tricher. On voit tout de suite, quelles sont les vraies expressions
Contrairement, aux idées reçues, c'est pas Paul Ekman qui a découvert les micros expressions, comme tout le monde le dit, tout le monde le croit depuis la série Lie To Me
Même si, il a fait beaucoup pour le sujet
Le premier a s'être intéressé à ça, au niveau des humains et des animaux c'est Darwin
qui a publié, en 1872, un livre là-dessus
"L'expressions des émotions chez l'homme et les animaux"
mais c'est seulement en 1966 que Haggard et Isaacs ont inventé, employé du moins, le terme micro expression, c'est les premiers à avoir fait ça
ils ont utilisé ce terme là, après avoir visionné des films de psychanalyste avec le patient et le psychanalyste qui était en face.
Ils ont regardé ça avec des ralentis
ils ont étudié ça à ce moment là et ils ont dit ça c'est une micro expression, Monsieur.
Et c'est seulement au début des années 90 que Paul Ekman a apporté sa pierre à l'édifice avec d'énormes travaux là-dessus.
Il a d'ailleurs détecté des nouvelles émotions par rapport à celle qui existait déjà.
mais ça, je vous en parlerais après.
Et c'est lui qui a inspiré la série Lie To Me, que vous connaissez
Il a était consultant pour cette série, coach des comédiens, ce qui fait que c'était assez précis, en fait,
tout ce qu'on voit dans cette série est plutôt précis et réel.
Quand je dis tout, c'est pas tout non plus, je vous vois venir dans les commentaires
mais c'est quand même un support précis qui n'existait pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui même si c'est fait sous forme de fiction.
Aujourd'hui, on dit, par convention qu'il y a 7 micros expressions différentes, que vous pouvez détecter en parlant avec quelqu'un
c'est à dire, vous discutez avec quelqu'un et elles passent très rapidement
Souvenez vous 1/25 de seconde 1/16 de seconde
si vous arrivez à la détecter vous savez ce que pense réellement la personne, au moment, où elle vous parle
La première c'est la joie, la vrai joie, la joie sincère, avec le vrai sourire
où les joues se tendent réellement vers le haut
où c'est pas juste les pommettes qu'on aide à remonter
il y a comme des petites rides qui apparaissent autour des yeux
ce qu'on appelle les pattes d'oie.
La bouche qui s'ouvre pour commencer à sourire.
Des fois même pour faire un sourire
C'est d'ailleurs ça, qu'on appelle le sourire authentique.
Le sourire authentique c'est un sourire qu'on ne peut pas refréner, on peut pas le garder, on peut pas le retenir.
et à ce moment là, le muscle orbiculaire sourit en même temps que la bouche
C'est ça qu'on appelle... les yeux rieurs
En deuxième micro expression universelle
puisque je crois que je ne vous l'ai pas précisé mais elles sont universelles c'est à dire
que ce soit une tribu dans le fin fond du monde qui n'a pas de contact avec les autres ou
une civilisation européenne ou asiatique
On a tous la même manière d'exprimer ces émotions là.
C'est pour ça que c'est l'une des clés les plus importantes du non-verbal
Je disais donc en deuxième la surprise avec les yeux qui s'écarquillent, la bouche qui s'ouvre, et les sourcils qui remontent
mais les sourcils en entier, c'est à dire les intérieurs, les extérieurs
En troisième la colère, avec la mâchoire crispée
les lèvres qui se resserrent, les sourcils qui froncent
C'est à dire que les 2 pointes intérieures commencent à s'abaisser
En 4ème le dégoût avec cette partie là qui commence à remonter légèrement
ces 2 canaux là au niveau du nez
parfois un début de crispation et toujours la lèvre supérieure qui remonte.
Pas toute la bouche juste la lèvre supérieure
Un exemple concret de dégoût comme ça spontané et sincère
Je crois que c'est clair
En 5ème, le mépris qui est une micro expression très intéressante
puisque c'est la seule qui est asymétrique
il y a qu'une seule partie du visage, qui va rentrer en mouvement
et elle a, un côté, un peu illogique c'est à dire que plus les mouvements musculaires vont être faible et plus le mépris va être fort
parce qu'il y a une tentative de dissimuler
et ça c'est un signe que le mépris est encore plus fort.
avec pleins de représentations différentes
quelque choses qui est toujours commun au mépris c'est une partie des lèvres qui commence à se contracter.
Comme sur cette photo ou cette photo de personnes prises complètement au hasard
Evidemment
Pour l'anecdote, cette micro expression, elle est passé sur son visage...
lors du débat en 2007 qu'il avait face à Ségolène Royal pour les présidentielles où il lui avait dit:
"Et alors... les 35h vous en faites quoi?"
La 6ème avec des yeux qui s'écarquillent,
avec les sourcils qui remontent, sauf la partie intérieure qui s'abaisse avec la lèvre qui s'entrouve
*Roulement de tambours*
La peur
J'ai une image très intéressante concernant la peur, c'est avec Miss Caroline du Sud
Où là, on voit bien qu'elle a un sourire de façade qui est mis pour les jurés, pour le public, pour les gens qui la regarde à la télévision.
Mais si on oublie, ce sourire qui est faux.
Et qu'on regarde les yeux, les yeux sont écarquillés
Les sourcils remontent, ils s'abaissent. Tout les muscles de la peur sont en marche
en fait, elle est en stress et elle a vraiment peur dans ce moment là.
et enfin la 7ème micro expression universelle c'est celle de la tristesse
avec tout le visage qui se détend, qui s'abaisse
et la bouche qui forme une espèce de U inversé
pour ceux qui aimerait aller plus loin dans les descriptifs
musculaires complets de tout ça
Je vous mets un lien dans le descriptif
Paul Ekman, lui, en a rajouté une 10aine à ces universelles là.
Alors, il y a un petit débat. Est ce qu' elles sont vraiment universelles ou pas?
parce que, d'une culture à une autre, il y a les choses qu'on appelle les sentiments
qui s'apprennent au contact, en fait, des gens qui nous entourent
et de la société donc on va avoir une manière d'exprimer telle ou telle chose
parce qu'on est né à tel ou tel endroit et que c'est plutôt ça qu'on fait là bas.
Néanmoins en universelle ou en quasi universelle, et puis si elles sont pas universelles,
elles sont quand même intéressantes pour les pays occidentaux
Ce sont les micros expressions de:
l'intérêt, l'excitation, la culpabilité, de la honte, de l'orgueil, du soulagement, de la satisfaction et du plaisir
On les appelle les émotions secondaires.
Alors c'est sûr c'est pas facile de détecter ça, il faut être très attentif dans une conversation, c'est même plus facile après, à regarder sur un film
mais vous pouvez essayer de le faire ou de vous entraînez à le faire
on peut déjà s'améliorer
à détecter ça, puisque si on y prête attention, forcément on est beaucoup plus présent à la discussion
et on les voit mieux passer.
Mais il y a des personnes qui sont plus sensible que d'autres à ça.
C'est même des petits génies des micros expressions
qui savent les détecter à 10 000 Km
J'exagère un peu là sur les 10 000 Km
En tout cas, qui n'en ratent pas une
Ekman a même créé un programme qui s'appelle Génie, qui est un espèce de programme de super détecteur de ces gens là.
Ils ont fait passer 20 000 personnes
sur ce programme. Et sur les 20 000, il y avait 50 personnes qui naturellement
savaient les détecter, les interpréter
C'était assez inconscient en fait...
un espèce de don.
Peut être que vous aussi vous arrivez à détecter des choses sur des gens ou que vous avez des anecdotes sur ce sujet
En ayant vu une micro expression passer ou en ayant détecté quelque chose d'un peu non verbal
pour interpréter une discussion
Mettez-le moi dans les commentaires, je serais ravi de lire ça et vos anecdotes à vous.
Petite précision, quand même, pour ceux qui vont essayer de le faire un peu comme sur la vidéo que j'avais fait sur le cold reading
que je vais vous mettre là, par là haut
je sais pas trop où ça va apparaître
Il est important d'avoir une base line et d'avoir plusieurs tell pour valider quelque chose
C'est à dire que c'est pas parce que vous détectez une micro expression particulière
qu'elle correspond à l'interprétation directe que vous en avez
Imaginez vous parler avec quelqu'un
une personne proche, à vous deux, qui est décédée il y a longtemps ou il y a pas longtemps
et vous voyez une micro expression de joie passer sur son visage.
Donc en interprétation directe on pourrait dire qu'il n'aimait pas cette personne
Alors que ça peut être au contraire
qu'il a un souvenir qui lui revient, un souvenir nostalgique
et qu'il est joyeux de ce souvenir là.
N'oubliez jamais que dans le non verbal, une chose ne suffit pas à une validation complète.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé ce master class sur les micros expressions
C'était le 1er, si vous voulez que j'en fasse un autre vous me le dites aussi dans les commentaires
Il y a pas de soucis, on pourra aller plus loin de toute manière je vous l'ai dit dans le descriptif
Vous retrouvez, quand même, des liens pour aller un petit peu plus loin que ça.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, en tout cas, merci de me le faire savoir en me laissant
Un pouce en l'air
et peut être qu'avec tout ces pouces en l'air, à un moment donné je vais regarder
la vidéo est moi aussi j'aurai une expression de joie
Elle est étrange ma joie
C'est une joie personnelle *rires*
C'est une micro expression personnelle
Pensez à vous abonner avant de partir puisque je vous rappelle que le Mental Vlog
C'est une vidéo par jour depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre
Donc rendez vous demain à 11h, parce que le week end c'est 11h
Ciao !